la parole est à monsieur jean françois
lamour monsieur le président tout
d'abord merci d'avoir évoqué la
disparition de notre collègue et amie
anne grommerch je pense que son sourire
et sa volonté hors du commun nous manque
déjà beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
après 10 et jean carré bloqué pendant
quatre mois en 2015 c'est au tour du
lycée jean jaurès situé dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris d'être bloqués
par plusieurs centaines de migrants
manipulé par un groupuscule d'extrême
gauche dans son principe cette
occupation est la négation totale et
frontale de l'état de droit dans ses
conséquences
elle porte atteinte au droit à
l'éducation et à la formation
en effet loin d'être un bâtiment
désaffecté comme le prétend des
militants à l'origine de l'opération ce
lycée doit accueillir à la rentrée
prochaine les établissements d'un
établissement professionnel du 15e
arrondissement du même coup cette
situation inacceptable met en cause le
projet que nous portons avec mon
collègue philippe goujon d'ouvrir un
nouveau collège sur le site
ainsi libérées dans un contexte où le
15e arrondissement le plus peuplé de
paris souffre actuellement d'un déficit
de places en second degré
devant l'inaction de l'état la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse a déposé une demande de
référé afin d'obtenir l'évacuation des
lieux
alors ma question est simple elle
appelle une réponse toute aussi simple
de votre part ferez vous enfin preuve
d'autorité en ordonnant à la force
publique de rendre ce bâtiment à la
collectivité ou ferez vous à nouveau
preuve de complaisance en étant c'est le
cas place de la république
une poignée d'agitateurs prendre en
otage la société française toute entière
merci la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazenave ministre de l'intérieur le
député gondjout remercie pour votre
question qui me permet d'apporter toutes
les précisions utiles
d'abord monsieur le député nous sommes
dans un état de droit
et comme vous le venez de le rappeler
l'état de droit suppose que les règles
soient appliquées quelles sont les
règles en la matière
ces bâtiments appartiennent au conseil
régional il n'est donc pas possible en
droit à l'état de procéder à
l'évacuation de ses bâtiments aussi
longtemps aussi longtemps que le conseil
régional qui en a convenu d'ailleurs
dans la relation qu'il a avec le
ministère de l'intérieur ne saisit pas
le tribunal administratif afin que celui
ci délivre une ordonnance d'évacuation
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
la présidente du conseil régional dans
sa grande sagesse a saisi hier le
tribunal administratif en urgence de
telle sorte à ce que celui ci se
prononce et permettent à l'état de
procéder en droit à l'évacuation de ses
locaux il y a donc une très bonne
relation entre le conseil régional et le
ministère de l'intérieur pour que dans
le respect rigoureux des règles de droit
nous puissions procéder à cette
évacuation et je regrette sincèrement
que vous n'ayez pas été informés de cela
bien entendu quand le tribunal
administratif se sera prononcé comme la
présidente a demandé à ce que ils le
fassent dans l'urgence nous procéderons
dans les heures qui suivront comme nous
l'avons fait jusqu'à présent à
l'évacuation de ses locaux et pour votre
parfaite information monsieur le député
il faut vous sachiez depuis le 2 juin
nous avons procédé à 18 évacuations
selon les modalités de droit que je
viens d'indiquer qu'ils ont permis
l'évacuation de 6700 migrants qui ont
tous été hébergés dans 55 centres dédiés
et que nous continuerons à le faire avec
fermeté et humanité dans le respect du
droit
parce que ces sujets aussi ne souffre
aucune approximation et aucune outrance
merci monsieur le ministre